nous avons un foie d'oie de bretagne il
doit être ferme qui doit être de pas
trop élastique et qu'il faut travailler
le plus ferme possible ça dit il ne faut
pas le laisser dehors trop longtemps
avant de s'en servir
je tranche donc de deux tranches pas
trop épaisses de façon à ce que pendant
la cuisson la chaleur pénètre bien
partout et que le poids ne comporte que
le foie d'oie est un élément très gras
tous les trois grades ailleurs
ensuite je sais zone mais tranche avant
de l'est parce qu'à la farine
et je vais là les mettre dans une petit
square où j'ai mis un petit beurre blanc
je les retourne je le laisse une ou deux
minutes je les reçois et je vais
débarrasser sur deux assiettes
ensuite j'ai réservé des grains de
raisin et pelé un par un et je les fait
revenir aussi dans un petit peu de
beurre ou dans le reste de de graisse
défense de fois et je les dépose autour
du avec la france deux fois sur
l'assiette et pour terminer je fais une
petite sauce à base de glace devient une
liasse de vianne et un fond très réduits
à base d'extrait devient dos
et je demande le to over après avoir
assaisonner sel poids et genappe
et on en voit ça un échappé